in this video I want to talk about the
quarry cycle the quarry cycle is an
example actually of substrate cycling
which is just the idea that we can have
two different reverse processes
occurring at the same time but in this
case we're going to talk about
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis occurring
at the same time if you recall before we
mentioned that you can't have Baikal
assist and gluconeogenesis going on in
the same cell at the same time that
would it make sense why would you want
to break down glucose and make glucose
at the same time doesn't make sense
so then how would both of these
processes be occurring at the same time
how is this possible what would we do
they both be happening but just in
different cells so the example follows
with if a particular human is having you
know a workout of some sort they're
exercising anaerobically without oxygen
okay so they're gonna their muscle cells
they're going to be working them and
their muscles are going to be doing
undergoing glycolysis so glycolysis will
be occurring in their muscles and will
be converting glucose into pyruvate and
they'll be making ATP anaerobically
now when that happens in order to
continue glycolysis we need a particular
process to occur and so that we can
regenerate NAD+ --is because if we have
a buildup of nadh --is we need to re
oxidize those NADH is back contain they
put nad plus so that we can have them
available for glycolysis because they
are a physical requirement of what
causes and that process is called
fermentation and this hopefully is all
review so if we're undergoing
fermentation to regenerate NAD+ is's if
you recall that was lactate fermentation
so pyruvate was turned into lactate so
as to regenerate and ID pluses from the
NADH s that are formed so lactate is a
poison and lactate is I mean it's it's a
conjugate base of Lac
pick acid and we don't want lactic acid
buildup in ourselves it's it's toxic to
ourselves and if you would like more
about that go ahead and Google like
lactic acid poisoning if you don't
already know there's an organ in our
body that is involved in detoxifying
poisons and that organ is the liver
so this lactate is taken to the liver to
be reoxidized to pyruvate and then once
we have these pyruvates gluconeogenesis
occurs to make glucose in the liver so
this glucose then can go back to the
muscle cells for glycolysis so what's
going on here we're having glycolysis
occurring in the muscles while
gluconeogenesis is occurring in the
liver they're both happening at the same
time to get a visual on this little
diagram here if we imagine this guy this
is a really buff dude okay and he went
through to the gym because he wanted to
get a good arm workout so he wanted to
work his biceps which i brilliantly
drawn here so I've labeled his muscles
his bicep muscle here and noted in red
and this purple thing here is his liver
so he's gonna be doing some bicep curls
and that's going to eat it's gonna be a
quick and vigorous workout and when he's
doing this these muscle cells are going
to need to be be going through by kalus
so what's going to happen they mean
these muscle cells need ATP so that's
what they're going to do they're going
to undergo glycolysis so with glycolysis
occurs they're going to have their
glucose right and they're going to turn
it into pyruvate and of course make
those a-gps but once we have this
pyruvate because there's no oxygen
around we can't go through the TCA cycle
which I haven't made videos on they're
actually coming up next but the pyruvate
once it's around it needs to be
converted into lactate right through
fermentation so as to regenerate these
NAD+ --is but then like I said this
lactate is toxic to our to our cells so
our body takes that lactate from our
muscle cells so this
this this is all happening in the
muscles okay this process here actually
boxed it in red so that you can know
that is occurring in the muscles this
lactate right is going to go through our
blood okay all the way to our liver okay
so there's no black T is going to go
from here from the muscles to our liver
via the blood circulation
now when that lactate get to the liver
it's going to be turned back into a
pyruvate and that pyruvate will you for
every two pyruvate they are you're going
to take those and turn them back into
glucose now once you've created that
glucose the liver can then dump that
into the blood and the blood can carry
that glucose back to the muscle cell and
the muscle cell can can have another
glucose that it can break down that's
basically the Cori cycle hope that was
helpful and thank you for watching